now the BBC says that it won't resume
filming of Top Gear's latest series
that's after the presenter Freddie
flintoff was injured in a crash last
year the former cricketer was taken to
hospital after the accident in December
he's been silent on social media ever
since the BBC hasn't commented on
reports that flintoff has quit the show
well we're joined Now by Perry McCarthy
those of you who were regular viewers of
the show May well know he is a racing
driver and the original Stig on Top Gear
really good to see you at Perry this
morning thank you for joining us
um are you surprised by what's happened
I'm a bit surprised to be honest because
it's well the thing we don't know is
exactly what's happened it seems to be
shrouded in secrecy I can only wish
Freddie well if he's still unwell from
that accident but we don't really know
from such circumstances of it but this
is what comes of you know that they have
to be really careful about placing
untrained presenters in a very difficult
and high-speed situation and they should
now learn from that so I don't really
understand why they're choosing this to
cancel the show can it not be learned
from and applied
well it's happened before hasn't it so I
guess the question is has it happened
too many times
well yeah I mean the Richard's one
Richard Hammond's crash in the jet car
nobody nobody from my background would
have saved that particular accident that
was such a big car failure but you know
everything one never stops learning do
they and I just wonder is that is it
some kind of excuse to cancel Top Gear I
don't know what their viewing figures
are but I can tell you it's an expensive
show to make it just seems surprising to
me that they've jumped to this like
Freddy's had an accident nobody really
knows what's going on and now filming's
gonna be stopped it's it's bizarre and
Perry what can you tell us about what
goes on behind the scenes I mean how
much focus is there on on safety how
much training is there and indeed are
are some of the presenters encouraged to
really go hell for leather and take
risks
you've always got this thing of course
because the show is about enthusiasm
it's about cars and the presenters of
course are enthusiastic people but they
need to be reined in currently I'm not
sure what health and safety measures
there are but it needs to be applied by
people who understand risk one thing I
can tell you about motorizing or
anything driving full stop is when
something goes wrong it goes wrong very
very quickly so people from my
background stand a chance of getting
something back if it's gone wrong people
are untrained are more likely to have an
accident however it depends on location
so if you're out in an Airfield such as
the Top Gear test track there's a lot
less opportunity to have a big crash
because it's so much more open but if
you put in untrained presenters in a
high-speed car and then the pressure's
on to go quickly well in the location
they're at there's more things to hear
that's where they have to think and
learn from a few future but as I say I
have no idea how to come to the
conclusion that I can't learn and
they're canceling the show
yeah I mean I think you're you're
talking about two different things there
there's the environmental factors so
that so the terrain and the type of the
car and the type of driver but then
there's also the culture isn't there of
the program and that's really what I'm
what I'm getting at
um are are the drivers encouraged to
really take unnecessary risks do you
think and therefore
um is the future of the show in jeopardy
well the future the show seems to me in
Jeopardy but as you as you've pointed
out that risk factor but my point is you
can have lots of Glamor you can have
lots of power you can have lots of speed
um but with little risk if it's in the
right a more open environment taking
that somewhere else then personally I
believe that you need people with a lot
more experience behind the wheel so it's
a it's horses for horses where do you
want them to have this fun but it for me
personally I think it needs to be
limited so there's an expectation and
you shouldn't be pushing these guys too
far to deliver that
and it sounds to me from what you're
saying that you don't know what's going
on with Freddie flintoff
but it doesn't appear anybody does
because I've checked it out because you
know as a driver a presenter I'm teens
and you know here that Freddie's
actually okay you know that's my first
thought but there seems to be very
little information about the nature of
the accident how it was caused where it
was what went wrong so unless I'm
missing something somebody's Keen that
this doesn't get shown out why
all right Perry McCarthy good to talk to
you thank you very much